Salif and his friends cautiously make
their way back to their hideout in
Morocco's hills near the spanish
enclaves of silt'e they say the police
could show up at any moment and
dismantle it each of them has travelled
thousands of kilometres to come here now
it's a few hundred metres to reach
European territory on the other side of
the co2 border fence this young man from
Guinea shows us deep cuts he says he
suffered during his attempts to scale
the border fence my father is dead my
mother has nothing not even enough to
eat I'm the oldest son and I'm going to
try to do something to help her that's
why I set out it's been 2 years since
they left Guinea and now they're stuck
here among an estimated 50,000 people
waiting in Morocco to cross into Europe
Salif has been looking for his chance
for about half a year now living on
almost nothing the fence is his last
obstacle I have many friends who've made
it to Europe many of them jumped the
border just recently we trust in God
that one day we'll make it to say Utah
built its border fence to stop them
running 8 kilometers it's topped with
razor wire this and the border around
Spain's other enclaved meliha are the
European Union's only land borders with
Africa on the other side of it Alfonso
cruzado of the Spanish Gardea Seville
has to patrol this border he's not
always successful in late July around
600 migrants stormed the fence
the police were helpless against them
and reported more violence than ever
from the refugees who attacked with
homemade flamethrowers quicklime and
grappling hooks they were very well
organized and prepared
even worse they were so violent that we
couldn't even reach the fence itself
they threw acid at us and put all their
efforts into keeping us from patching up
the holes they'd cut in the fence they
yelled basa basa or victory after so
many years they had reached their
destination the transit camp in SE Utah
is overcrowded migrants have to stay
here for a year before they can move on
to the Spanish mainland hardly any of
them apply for asylum their chances of
getting it are next to none the town of
just 80,000 is struggling to cope with
the added burden a city councilor
accuses Spain of leaving them to deal
with the problem on their own they have
to respect the borders we can't have the
migrants attacking our fence the
theabout up or there and we don't have
the capacity to take in everyone that
would be impossible
data is impossible a thorough checks at
suitors border crossing are the norm so
are the hours of waiting twenty thousand
people enter and exit every day many
Moroccans live from the trade with this
autonomous Spanish town
watching the border is a Herculean task
for Alfonso Cruzado and the gardius
Seville about 600 staff are always on
duty they use video cameras to monitor
the fences various sections as well as
the sea in the Strait of Gibraltar the
team has reached their limits Casa de
personas is taken together it's no
simple thing to hold off huge crowds of
people
the Moroccan authorities and ours need a
very good working relationship if both
sides coordinate their efforts and
things go smoothly we achieve our
objectives
Sheikh Omar Knievel the young man in the
hills of Morocco have also realized
their strength in numbers Salif and his
friends are planning their next attempt
now they also want to escape the
brutality of the Moroccan police they
get their food from a nearby garbage
dump a soft drink a cucumber a moldy
potato life here is unbearable Morocco
is teeming with cops all my friends who
left Kimi with me have made it as far as
they why should I stay Morocco I'll stay
until I eventually get in God willing it
can be hard to distinguish courage from
desperation for Salif and his friends
it's Europe or bust